the mayor of mariopol in southern
ukraine says the city is on the brink of
a humanitarian catastrophe and must be
completely evacuated as soon as possible
mario paul has endured relentless
bombardment from russian forces in
recent weeks and mayor vadim buchenko
says nearly 5 000 people have died and
some 160 000 civilians remain in the
city without any power there is growing
concern that the city could soon fall
under russian control
meanwhile ukraine's defense ministry
says there is no evidence that russia is
planning to abandon its effort to
capture the capital kiev russian forces
are also stepping up their attacks in
eastern ukraine
[Music]
for just a few brief moments musicians
provided those inside this
metro station and bomb shelter with a
brief respite from the war
[Music]
music is a ray of light that helps our
souls survive
it brightens our lives stops us
panicking
and keeps away the darkness gloom and
bitterness of this war
we all need support like never before
if we classical musicians can provide
support to the people by playing our
instruments by doing what we can do best
we will do it anywhere
but across ukraine and with each day
that passes the death toll increases
this watch belonged to one of the war's
victims his son victor witnessed his
death
the russian soldiers just started firing
i looked at my dad
looked into the car
he was already choking on his own blood
i saw four direct hits to the windshield
but there is a faint glimmer of hope the
peace will return here in kiev the
president offered moscow a compromise on
the donbas this is peace talks between
russia and ukraine are set to resume on
tuesday in turkey
i understand it's impossible to make
russia give up the territory completely
that would lead to world war iii i
understand completely i'm aware of that
that's why i'm saying this is a
compromise but let's try to resolve the
question of the donbass the complex
question of the donbass
but in moscow there appears to be no
shift in russia's demands
we have to make sure that ukraine stops
assimilating itself with the west with
nato in the military sense
with threats to the russian federation
physical military threats to the russian
federation
death and destruction in ukraine
here in lev the funeral of a soldier
another day that a family has been
touched by the war
and for the latest we're joined now from
the ukrainian capital kiev by dw
correspondent matthias berlinger
matthias tell us what might a possible
compromise for a ceasefire look like
from a ukrainian perspective
well a compromise will be not where the
ukraine where ukraine sees the likely
outcome otherwise it wouldn't be a
compromise and i wouldn't uh think too
much about the outcome of any of these
talks right now for now i think this is
decided on the battlefield and the any
compromise will be uh reached when one
of the sides feels the need to back down
and this is not what we are seeing right
now we have seen some
um readiness to talk by russia that was
in the beginning saying that uh they
were
basically just setting their demands
zelensky said they were basically
setting an ultimatum um and we see some
things that zelensky has brought in this
neutrality issue but i also here i
wouldn't see too much of uh um
of of a position to give in here said he
would be ready to discuss this but that
also this had to be uh confirmed in a
referendum uh so he would not take the
responsibility for this hugely unpopular
uh com for com compromise that would be
so hugely unpopular i don't see that
these talks um
are serving in
at anything beyond keeping the channels
open trying to feel the positions i
don't think they're going towards any
result at the moment so it doesn't make
sense to talk about outcomes yet
give us a sense of the situation on the
ground in kiev where you are with this
new round of negotiations about to start
[Music]
yeah and kiev the situation is unchanged
what we're hearing is that around the
city in the northeast and in the
northwest and in the east uh
yesterday there was fierce fighting we
could hear it here in the city that the
shelling was more intense than otherwise
and it's quite calm now we've heard that
ukrainian forces have regained some
territory there um otherwise life is
going on here the cities has been
surrounded from uh
about 180 180 degrees so about half of
the ring of the city is closed
since almost since the beginning of the
war so there are not so many changes and
these negotiations of course people are
following after them but what's more
important for their life now is what's
going on in the fighting zones and
what's going on in the places where the
refugees come from uh this is what
people look at not so much of these
negotiations
dw correspondent matthias burlinger
reporting from kiev thank you
the german chancellor olaf charlotte's
has called for eu accession talks for
albania and north macedonia to begin as
soon as possible schultz made the
comments after a meeting with sweden's
prime minister magdalena anderson here
in berlin he said it was important that
the eu sped up talks with the two balkan
nations to prevent them from being
pulled into russia's sphere of influence
charlottes and anderson also discussed
the question of swedish neutrality as
the country considers
nato membership anderson said its eu
membership meant sweden was no longer a
neutral country his german chancellor
olaf
magdalena and myself agree that we want
to strengthen the eu and make it more
resilient as well
the turning point in history is
something that means we must achieve
real progress within the european union
thus we talked about the fact that the
time has come
to
have the albanian and macedonian
accession talks
begin
as soon as possible otherwise these
balkan states will be vulnerable for
russian influencing
and we need to
strengthen our capacity
in a number of different ways
dw spoke to swedish prime minister
magdalena anderson after that press
conference we asked her about schultz's
comments about eu accession talks with
albania north macedonia here's what she
had to say
well i mean countries should be able to
join the european union when they are
ready for it and i think it's important
that all countries can have a process
coming closer to a european membership
and from a swedish perspective we have
been supporting countries for instance
ukraine uh to help build their
institutions to become so they could
come closer to becoming members of the
european union attacking ukraine was not
only an attack on ukraine but also on
the european security order which means
that every country can make their
decision themselves so of course we then
we have the right to do the decision
that we think is right for our country
but of course when we do we do that we
have to
weigh all the different risks with the
different options that we have the
situation in around the baltic sea has
changed after russia's invasion of
ukraine we've had a deteriorating
security situation around the baltic for
a long time but this was really a shift
what we have done from a swedish
perspective during the last years is to
increase our defense spending and we
also follow germany to go up to two
percent of gdp but we also increased our
bilateral multilateral cooperation like
being a partner to nato with a very
close close cooperation to with
finland but also with the joint
expeditionary force with with other
countries and we will continue in this
direction but we also have a discussion
with the other parties in parliament to
analyze the situation and see what that
means for
how we will act in the future and in the
ukrainian city of la viv is our
correspondent amy and essev for us
tonight it's good to see you amiens so
we are in week five of this war what is
the situation there in western ukraine
well brent i'm actually speaking to you
from the basement of the building that
i'm staying in which serves as a bomb
shelter there's been um air raid sirens
going off uh this is the second time
today so it's the second time i've had
to go down to the bomb shelter um there
were strikes four
more than 48 hours ago
around
this city oil uh reserves
from russian missiles launched all the
way from crimea so it has people
startled here but there haven't been any
missile attacks um
for over 48 hours but there were reports
of attacks um just 150 kilometers north
of here you probably can hear kids
playing around here right now people are
trying to make the best of it because
this happens uh daily
it's not more than once a day that we
have to uh when the air raid sirens go
to go downstairs but
look uh a lot of this is
symbolic strikes from the russian
military because the real fighting is
happening the real suffering is
happening in eastern ukraine uh the
donbass um kharkiv mariupol and um even
a lot more in kiev than it is here in
western ukraine brand yeah you know i'm
hearing those children knowing that
they're sharing the same space with you
um in a bomb shelter and that we're
talking about war and peace it you know
it just speaks to the brutal reality
of
this conflict and what about
a possible
ceasefire we know that there is at least
one new idea that's being floated
from the ukrainian perspective what can
you tell us about that
ceasefire has
become more real because of these
comments from the ukrainian presidents
basically what he said is that
he's willing to talk he's willing to
give uh ukrainian neutrality so he has
hinted before that this would be on the
table but it sounds in his remarks that
this is the furthest he's gone and said
that a neutrality would be an option of
course he said he would have to put this
up to
a referendum in the country and just
speaking to the people here on the
ground i don't know how many people
would vote for anything that would give
russia any kind of uh advantage here or
give them any ground now the donbass is
a different question basically what uh
zalenski said was that instead of
demanding that all russian troops leave
the country he would reset to basically
february 23rd before the russian uh
complete the complete russian invasion
of this country
and then decide the question of the
donbass
after that
they went back to that being the only
disputed territory but then the russian
troops would be out of the rest of the
country uh
like uh in kiev for example
i mean let me just ask you before we run
out of time the ukrainian government we
understand investigating possible
torture of russian soldiers by its
troops what are the allegations
well this is an interesting case brian
it's also interesting to see how the
ukrainian government reacted there were
videos circulating yesterday mostly on
pro-russian accounts on social media i'm
showing gruesome videos i watch this
myself i don't recommend watching it it
is
it is truly torture if it is real um
showing videos of soldiers shooting
ukrainian soldiers shooting russians in
the leg
as soon as they got out of the truck uh
breaking their bones beating them into
almost so that they're unrecognizable
now the government first said that
this was fake videos that this was
russian disinformation but um then they
said that if it were true they're going
to investigate it they will punish
anybody who was involved if it turns out
to be true because they said ukrainian
army is a european army and they follow
international standards and this indeed
if it was true would be a crime and
needs to be punished
our correspondent ami and essev in the
western ukrainian city of levive tonight
ami and thank you
you